schluss aus vorbei erst mal mit party
doch was wenn ich gerade deshalb mein
mallorca urlaub gebucht habe kann ich
wegen ein paar geschlossener lokale
meine ganze reise jetzt stornieren
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt reise
rechtsanwältin nicole mutschke ganz
herzlich willkommen heute morgen bei
bild hallo
ja also die party zentren sind zumindest
teilweise geschlossen
was kann ich jetzt tun mit diesen
einschränkungen muss ich das in kauf
nehmen oder kann ich jetzt zu meinem
reiseveranstalter sagen ich bin ja aber
wegen schinken und bier straße nach
mallorca geflogen jetzt geht das alles
nicht mehr
jetzt möchte ich zurücktreten von meiner
reise grundsätzlich ist das nicht sehr
einfach überhaupt ein kostenloser
rücktritt ist nur bei pauschalreisen
möglich und auch da liegt die hürde sehr
hoch man muss eine erhebliche
beeinträchtigung der reise haben und da
ist zum beispiel die reisewarnung des
auswärtigen amtes so ein maßstab der zb
dann hilft aber ein paar geschlossene
geschäfte auch wenn es die partymeile
ist das wird nicht ausreichend für eine
kostenlose stornierung aber ab wann kann
ich denn stornieren andersrum gefragt
was muss denn der reiseveranstalter mir
garantieren für eine reise die
tatsächlich stattfinden kann erreichter
der flug und das hotelbett
tatsächlich kommt es auch den
reisevertrag an also da muss man ganz
genau angucken was es zugesagt also zum
beispiel der meerblick und wenn er dann
nicht da ist dann gibt es aber erstmal
nur eine minderung des reisepreises auch
das führt dann nicht sofort dazu dass
sich die komplette reise stornieren kann
sondern eben wenn bestimmte leistungen
fehlen dann erstmal nur die reise
mindern
und dann haben wir ja immer das thema
der reiserücktritt versicherung greift
die bei solchen corona sperrungen jetzt
also ich habe sie vorher abgeschlossen
die rücktrittsversicherung jetzt sage
ich neben mallorca macht jetzt keinen
sinn mehr greift so eine versicherung
eine sehr häufige frage aber leider kann
man sie sehr eindeutig beantworten eine
reiserücktrittsversicherung sichert nur
persönlich
die umstände ab die mir sozusagen
unmöglich machen dass ich verreise
klassisches beispiel meine eigene
krankheit dann kann ich nicht verreisen
aber die situation vor ort die hilft bei
der reiserücktrittsversicherung leider
gar nicht und was muss ich denn
sozusagen dulden also welchen spielraum
haben den reiseunternehmen in solchen
corona lagen beispielsweise ganz anderes
hotel als ich gebucht habe ist sowas in
kauf zu nehmen
tatsächlich wird das natürlich zur zeit
ganz stark diskutiert und es ist immer
eine abwägungssache man muss halt
wirklich gucken ist die einschränkung so
stark dass ich nur eine minderung des
reisepreises vornehmen kann am ende des
tages oder ist die änderung so erheblich
also ganz was anderes dass ich
tatsächlich schon vorher eine kostenlose
stornierung vornehmen kann
das muss man wirklich im einzelfall
sehen ich weiß das ist unbefriedigend
aber da ist das reiserecht leider sehr
sehr unklar das heißt man muss wirklich
gucken was kann man alles an argumenten
bringen und was liegt mir einzelfall vor
und mallorca ist ja auch eine reise wert
ohne ballermann ohne schinkenstraße
nicole mutschke ganz herzlichen dank
reise rechtsanwältin dann gehen